it's not the holidays without cookies
everybody that's right yeah this one
would have a little bit of fun and with
the Good Day Las Vegas inaugural yeah
we have been given two minutes to design
our own cookie using only what's in
front of us Sherry yes we've got icing
we've got sprinkles then you at home
will vote for
[Music]
you all right here we go okay
let's get started okay
now presumably right now lots of folks
are doing this uh on their weekends when
they're decorating cakes and cookies and
whatnot and if I was doing this at home
it would be like I'd be taking a bite
and then decorating and then taking
another bite and decorating prices is a
disaster by there already this is a
disaster
can't be a disaster
you got this all right John have you
ever decorated a cookie before uh no
didn't your mom teach you anything she
taught me how to eat them not to not the
decorate them
I think mine's going to win just for the
record how much time do you have left
118
118. okay I'm almost done
[Music]
is to use all the decorations is it oh
see earlier you were saying to use one
of them yeah see that was my that was
part of my game plan oh the reverse
psychology yeah
oh my gosh one minute
it's a disaster it's stressful this is
hard time
I think I'm done
[Music]
thank you
the kids at Rundle Elementary were
Candace was by the way would love this
cookie for the record this cookie is
going to blow their minds John are you
kidding oh my God John that was like
that is like I don't know what's
happening all right I gotta use my
fingers here
how much time all right
[Music]
here we go
all right I'm done I like colors
oh with a knife and fork that's about it
all right okay all right I did it
we're done
[Music]
all right surgery is over okay well can
we show them off okay yeah yeah because
all right people at home you have to
vote on these yes on the website or on
our social media Pages upstairs
yeah so I made my cartoon character his
name is C urchin
um I did a strand of Holiday Lights oh
how cute I don't know if you can see but
there you go there's yours is really
loud it looks like Zorro
John this is this is the kitchen sink oh
my goodness
that one grow up a little bit but okay
and this is mine this is my uh pink
Christmas tree oh Siri it's so cute with
snow that is really nice snow on the
bottom oh I kind of went overboard oh my
gosh
overboard on the uh
no such thing as too much icing these
are our cookies vote online don't pick
which one you think are the bestest and
we'll talk about them next year said she
would bribe yeah I don't know I might be
willing to help out on that it's 6 56
again vote online we'll talk about it
next week but first we should point out
it's Flutie Friday take it away